Good morning Hank. It's Tuesday.
So I am a total sucker for airport reunions,
and because I've spent about a third of my
adult life in airports, I've seen a lot of
them over the years.
But a couple weeks ago, I got to see…
Well, okay, so this is Saw Kyar Aye, waiting
at the airport for his wife and son.
He was born in Burma, also known as Myanmar,
and as a young man he was taken from his community
by the army and forced to work on road construction.
The conditions for forced labor in Burma are
horrible, and it remains a problem despite
the steps toward democracy the country has
made in the past decade.
Beatings by soldiers are common, and deserters
have been executed.
Persecution of religious and ethnic minorities
is also common, and Saw Kyar Aye is both—he
is a Christian and a member of the ethnic
Chin minority.
Saw Kyar Aye escaped his forced labor crew
in 2008 and eventually found his way to Malaysia,
where he registered as a refugee with UNHCR,
but because he couldn’t legally work in
Malaysia, he had to live on the margins of
the social order.
Then again, he couldn’t risk returning home,
because now he would be considered a deserter.
He did consider himself lucky, though, to
find unofficial work in a restaurant, where
he met Thet Thet, a fellow Burmese refugee
who was a waitress in that restaurant.
They fell in love and got married, but their
refugee cases were being processed separately.
The bureaucracy faced by refugees is often
quite dizzying.
There are so many layers of vetting and checking,
and only a tiny fraction of people are ever
approved for resettlement.
Also, critically, if you do get approved for
resettlement, that news can come at any time,
and when it does, you have once chance to
take it or leave it.
So in 2012, four years after escaping to Malaysia,
Saw Kyar Aye received permission to come to
the United States, but because Thet Thet's
application was being vetted separately, she did not.
Together they decided that Aye should go,
partly because they'd been told it was easy
to reunite spouses once one was in the United
States.
So in December of 2012, with Thet Thet eight
months pregnant, Saw Kyar Aye left Malaysia
for Indianapolis.
There are more than 13,000 Burmese refugees
now living here in Indianapolis.
Saw Kyar Aye joined that community, but he
also joined the broader Indianapolis community.
He found a church and friends and a job—he
works in a Clif bar factory—but the very
first thing he did upon arriving was file
for family reunification.
Quick pause to note that refugee resettlement
has not increased U.S. crime rates in Indianapolis or elsewhere.
In fact, it is associated with community crime
rates dropping.
And also, there is little evidence that refugee
resettlement negatively affects employment or wages.
Sources in the video info below.
Right, so, it's the beginning of 2013.
Thet Thet is in Malaysia, caring for her baby
son, Saw Kyar Min, working when she can.
The family seems certain to be reunited soon,
but delays keep happening until finally, in
April of 2014, Saw Kyar Aye learns that his
wife and son will be coming to the United States.
Except there is a clerical error.
It turns out that there are two Saw Kyar Ayes in
a refugee database, and Thet Thet has been
listed as being married to the other one,
so the trip is canceled, and the process starts again.
At last, in 2016, Thet Thet and Saw Kyar Min
are again approved for resettlement.
Visas are issued.
Travel plans made.
And then comes an executive order halting
all refugee resettlement into the United States
for at least 120 days.
Saw Kyar Aye said he started to wonder if
he would ever get a chance to see his son.
He'd prepared everything for the kid to start
school in Indiana, but now they would have
to wait again.
Would the refugee resettlement program ever
restart?
If so, would people already approved still
be at the front of the line, or would it be
2014 all over again?
But then, as suddenly as the executive order
arrived, a court ruled much of it invalid,
and days later, Thet Thet and Saw Kyar Min
were on a plane, first to New York and then to Indianapolis.
Saw Kyar Aye and I have both worked with a
local refugee resettlement organization called
Exodus, and through them, I was invited to
the airport for the reunion, and walking in,
I was so nervous.
Would there be another executive order?
A different court reaching a different ruling?
No. This time, I got to witness the best airport
reunion ever, as Saw Kyar Aye saw his wife
for the first time in over four years, and
held his son for the first time ever.
No one can seriously think that reuniting
this family poses a threat to the strength
or the prosperity of the United States, but
to be a refugee is to have much of your life
defined by powers far beyond your control.
Yesterday, a new blanket ban on refugee resettlement
was announced for at least 120 days, meaning
that many families who'd been praying for,
and told to expect, reunions like this one
will now have to wait.
Now, we can have—and we need to have—a discussion
about how many refugees should be resettled
in the United States each year, but a blanket
ban is a terrible way to start that conversation.
Instead, I believe that conversation must
start by seeing refugees as people with individual
stories, who love their families and want
them safe.
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.
P. S. Over at youtube.com/100days, my best friend
Chris and I are on a health and fitness journey,
and on day 100, we’re gonna run a 10K race.
You can sponsor us!
All the proceeds will go to Exodus, the refugee
resettlement organization here in Indianapolis.
Link in the dooblydoo below.
Thanks, bye!